let me ask you about the women running
running the world okay uh so gender does
in part perhaps shape the landscape of
just our Human Experience
um so in what ways was the limiting it
in what ways was it empowering for you
to be a woman in the Middle East
I think just kind of just going back to
like my comment on like women running
the world I think it comes back to
empathy right which which has been a
Common Thread throughout my my entire
career and it's this this idea of human
connection
um once you build common ground with a
person or a group of people you build
trust you build loyalty you build
um friendship and then and then you can
turn that into like Behavior change and
motivation and persuasion so so it's
like empathy and emotions are just at
the center of of everything we do
and and I think being being from the
Middle East kind of this human
connection is is very strong like we
have this running joke that if you come
to Egypt for a visit
people are gonna we'll know everything
about your life like right away right I
have no problems asking you about your
personal life
um there's no like No Boundaries really
no personal boundaries in terms of
getting to know people we get
emotionally intimate like very very
quickly but I think people just get to
know each other like
authentically I guess you know there
isn't this like superficial level of
getting to know people you just try to
get to know people really part of that
totally because you can put yourself in
this person's shoe and kind of
yeah imagine you know what what
challenges they're going through and
um so I think I've I've definitely taken
that with me
um
generosity is another one too like just
being generous with your time and love
and attention and even
with your wealth right even if you don't
have a lot of it you're still very
generous I think that's another
enjoying the humanity of other people
and so do you think there's a useful
difference between men and women
in that aspect and empathy
or is doing these kind of big General
groups does that hinder
progress
I don't I I actually don't want to over
generalize I mean I love the men I know
are like the most empathetic humans yeah
I strive to be yeah you're actually very
empathetic
um
yeah I thought so I don't want to over
generalize
um although one of the researchers I
worked with when I was at Cambridge
Professor Simon Baron Cohen he's uh
Sasha Baron Cohen's cousin yeah and he
runs the autism Research Center at
Cambridge and he's
written multiple books
um on autism and one of his one of his
theories is the empathy scale like the
systemizers and the empathizers and it
there's a disproportionate amount of
computer scientists and Engineers who
are systemizers and perhaps not great
empathizers
and then you know there's and there's
more men in that bucket I guess than
women and then there's more women in the
empathizer's bucket so again not not to
over generalize I sometimes wonder about
that is it's been frustrating to me how
many I guess systemizes there are in the
fields of robotics yeah it's actually
encouraging to me because I care about
obviously social Robotics and because uh
it's it it uh there's more opportunity
for people that are empathic exactly I
totally agree well right yes so
everybody said talk to they don't see
the the human as interesting as um
like it does it's not exciting you want
to avoid the human at all costs it's a
it's a safety concern to be touching the
human
um which it is but it's also an
opportunity for a deep connection or
collaboration or all that kind of stuff
so and because most most brilliant
roboticists don't care about the human
it's an opportunity right for in your
case it's a business opportunity too uh
but in general an opportunity to explore
those ideas